a cyclist starts pedaling and
accelerates for 12 seconds the velocity
v of t of the cyclist at two second
intervals in feet per second is given by
the table so they tell us a different
time so after four seconds velocity 7.5
feet per second after 8 seconds velocity
is
9 feet per second consider the graph of
velocity versus time
velocity versus time
let capital r of six be the sum of the
areas of six
right hand rectangles with equal
subdivisions
it follows that capital r of six is an
approximation for the total distance
traveled in feet during the 12 seconds
what is the value of capital r of 6. so
i encourage you to pause this video and
try to think about it on your own and
then i'll work through it at any time
while i'm working through it if you get
inspired feel free to pause again and
try to take it take it all the way
so let's let's think about what they're
saying they say consider the graph of
velocity versus time so we might as well
try to plot that and so got some graph
paper here
and we can focus on the first quadrant
because all of our time values and all
of our velocity values are positive
so let's see this is time
this is velocity as a function of time
axis time goes between 0 and 12 and
they're giving it to us in every 2
seconds so this is 0
2 4
6
8
10
and 12 seconds and then our velocity
goes between 0 and 10 feet per second so
this is 1
2 three four
five i'll just mark off some of them
six seven eight
nine ten and this is in
this is in feet
per second and this over here is in
seconds so let's plot these points at
time zero velocity is
zero
time two velocity is six feet per second
time four seven point five gets us right
there times six it's eight point five
that's eight eight point five
time
eight it eight seconds it's nine feet
per second
at 10 seconds it's 9.5 feet per second
and at 12 seconds it's 10 feet
it's 10 feet per second and so what i've
done here is i've just plotted the data
that they've given us this is the i'm
considering the graph of
velocity versus time at least the data
they've given us and so we can imagine
we can imagine fitting a curve that
looks something like this if we were to
that you know these points are just
sampled from a curve that might look
something like
something
like this
over there so we are now considering the
graph of velocity versus time now let's
think about the sum of the areas of six
right-handed rectangles with equal
subdivisions so when they're talking
about equal subdivisions they're talking
about equal subdivisions along the the
independent axis or the time axis in
this case and we're talking about the
first 12 seconds and so if we were to
divide the first 12 seconds into six
equal sections they would each be two
seconds wide
so this would be one of them let me do
this in a new color
so they would each be two seconds that's
not a new car it is blue so they're each
going to be two seconds we do one that
contrasts with green better
so they're each going to be each of our
rectangles are going to be two seconds
wide
and i'm just kind of starting them off
at the bottom because we have to think
about how tall to make them and then
they say to do right-handed rectangles
so what's a right-handed rectangle so
that means we define the height of the
rectangle by the value of the function
on the right-hand side so for example
this first rectangle to make it a
right-handed rectangle we look at okay
the right side we're at two seconds
velocity at two seconds is six feet per
second and so that's going to be the
height that's going to be the height of
our rectangle and so this next one is
going to look like this now you might
say well what's a left-handed rectangle
then well a left-handed rectangle would
be doing something like
would be doing something like okay for
this first rectangle on the left-hand
side of it my function is zero so it's
just zero then the next rectangle the
left hand side my function at or at two
seconds the function is six seconds so
the left hand side the left hand
the left hand rectangles would look like
this
would
would look something like that but
anyway they're telling us to do
right-handed rectangles so let's do
right-handed rectangles
so
let me clear this a little bit
all right so this is
a that's our first right-handed
rectangle this is our second one let me
just draw the tops
third
fourth
fifth and
sixth that was the tops of them
and it's just going to look something
like this it's going to look like this
so that's my third one
that's my fourth one
that's my
fifth one
and then
this is my
that's my sixth one and they're telling
us that our cat let capital r of six be
the sum of the areas of these things and
they tell us
they tell us that it follows that
capital r6 is an approximation for the
total distance traveled in feet during
the 12 seconds now why is that why is
the sum of these areas an approximation
for the total distance traveled well
well before calculus you learned you
learned
that if you have a constant rate that
distance is equal to rate
times time now once again this is
assuming that assumes a constant rate
now
our rate in this example is clearly
changing we are clearly accelerating
right over here but maybe we can
approximate the distance traveled if we
assume a constant rate over an interval
say over two second intervals and then
we just we try to roughly is when we
assume some velocity over that interval
now when we take these right-handed
rectangles let's just focus on this
first rectangle
if i'm taking the area of this first
rectangle
what am i doing i'm multiplying its
height times its width its height is
going to be the velocity at the end of
the two seconds and its width is the two
seconds so if i were to multiply six
feet per second times two seconds
that'll get me 12 feet let me make that
very clear
so the area for that one
area is equal to 6 feet per second my
velocity it's actually the speed but
we'll just assume we're not going to get
particular about whether we're getting
the direction as well six feet per
second times
times two seconds well that's going to
get me 12 that's going to get me 12 feet
now that we can say is an approximation
because we're saying okay you travel for
two seconds it's some sp at some
velocity but is that going to be an
overestimate or an underestimate
well it's going to be an overestimate
because you're taking the fastest
velocity of the interval the interval
started with the cycles going 0 feet per
second so it's clearly overestimating it
and if you think about it i encourage
you to pause the video and think about
it on your own if we did a left-handed
rectangle it would be underestimating it
because we'd be taking the slowest
velocity over the interval and
multiplying it by the interval but this
is an approximation
but let's just calculate what r of 6 is
so r 6
is going to be
the area of this rectangle which is
which is as we just said it's 6 feet per
second times 2 seconds so it's going to
be 12 feet
and then we have this rectangle which is
which is going to be let's see this is
7.5 feet per second times two seconds
which is going to be
15 feet
15 feet and you can even see it in the
area right over here it's going to be
three feet more one
two and then half of two of these so
it's going to be three feet more and
then the area of this one which is going
to be 8.5
so our velocity at the end of the
interval is 8.5 feet per second times 2
seconds which is 17
which is 17 feet
and then plus
plus this area
which is our velocity the end of the
interval
which is what is that that's nine feet
per second times two seconds so plus 18
and then we get the velocity this this
area which is going to be
this height the velocity at the end of
the interval which is 9.5 feet per
second times two seconds so plus
19 and then finally this area which is
the velocity at the end of the interval
which is 10 feet per second times 2
seconds so plus
20. and so what does this give us and
this is the the point at which i'm most
likely to make an error so 12 plus 15 is
12 plus 15 is 27
and then 27 plus 10 is 37 plus another 7
is 44 so that gives us 44. 44 plus 18
is going to give me let's see i can get
to
52 and then 62. so this is going to be
62 plus 19 is
let's see that's 81
plus 20 is 101 that's going to be in
feet
so capital r6 101 feet which is going to
it is an approximation for the total
distance traveled during the the 12
seconds but it's really a an over
approximation because we for every
interval we're taking the the fastest
velocity in the interval if we took the
slowest velocity interval it would be an
underestimate if we did left-handed
rectangles and we might have gotten
something in between if we saw maybe
took the average of these two so if we
made the height of the rectangle you
know three for this first one or
something like that but we'll do that in
future in future videos